you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer and I'm gonna do a group
of three puzzles and share my thoughts
along the way so in this first one
team white hmm oh okay this one doesn't
seem to be too bad this Bishop and rook
are on the same file there's the option
of pinning and that's probably the
solution there's no tricks after rook to
be one mm if d2 king takes and there's
no way for the rook to let's say move
and get out of the pin huh hey this one
isn't too bad
I don't think there's anything against
the King so my I basically tended
towards the Queen side of the board here
where I have some pressure noticing that
the tension on b5 attacker defender how
to take advantage of this rook to be one
should do the trick okay not a bad start
simply king takes and this pin is
present and that'll do it
hmm okay certainly encountered much more
difficult problems not bad to start
though get a not too difficult one in
the beginning okay let's see about this
one where we're playing as black okay
the first thing I'm thinking about is
that this pawn is pinning the King and
so I move like Queen g3 as possible this
pawn really isn't defending g3 if Queen
g3 King f1 Queen 6 f2 is mate and we
can't play here the Queen controls this
hmm let's see if I'm wondering if
there's a some quiet move we could make
but it's probably something direct here
this is a loose piece if we do a
material count in fact we're down a lot
of material so just trying to scoop this
up is no good
also for the reason of queen takes
bishop with checks so we have to be
pretty direct here queen g3 King h1 what
would we do there hmm for a moment I
thought about Queen g3 King h1 Bishop
takes F to controlling g1 and
threatening Queen h3 mate but that gives
a white time to do some checking moves
and stuff maybe checking on this
diagonal and I'd really don't want to
give white a moment to breathe I know I
don't want to give white a free move so
it should be pretty direct we could do a
little zigzag stuff like Queen g3 king
h1 and then try for Queen h4 I think
that might be it yeah I think that that
is it basically forcing the king to g1
and being able to take on f2 with check
or even Knight to h3 notice Queen g3
king h1 Queen h4 check King back to g1
now there's two interesting checks
available Knight h3 and Queen takes f2 I
wonder which one it would be from there
Queen G through so I'm pretty sure this
is that the first two moves at least
Queen g3 King h1 Queen h4 forcing King
back to g1 so basically this position
I'm trying to visualize it with the
Queen on h4 King ng is still on the same
square so with the Queen on h4 basically
what would we do take an f2 with the
Queen forcing king h1 and where can we
go if let's say this initial position
was there at the Queen on f2 and the
king in the corner what would we do
there I'm not really seeing it we don't
have g1 defended
now the rather I should say the rook
rook is defending g1 we can't go to g1
for me the diagonal is covered by the
Queen and well if we go back here what
would really be the difference we could
go back to h4 and give check so g3 check
King h1 Queen h4 check King g1 Queen
takes f2 check came back to h1 if we go
back to h4 oh that's actually made at
that point because the bishop would be
controlling g1 that is it then Queen g3
you see what I was just doing there is
trying to figure out the differences the
difference with this position with the
f2 pawn absent bias I saw that we could
go to g3 force king h1 Queen h4 check
force back King g1 take the pawn on f2
king h1 and then I tried to picture what
would be the difference without the pawn
on f2 it's that the bishop controls g1
directly so I think that this is it then
I'm making 1 2 3 4
Queen g3 king h1 Queen h4 check King g1
Queen takes f2 check King back to h1 and
then Queen h4
is me that is correct
so here check all forcing moves here
check and now finally Queen back and
that'll do it alright not too bad let's
see if we could go 3 4 3 and this one
team light
oh man seems like an endgame study hmm
I'm in ok tough yeah that's my first
thought is that this is tough
okay uh-huh yeah I'm already thinking
that this is some stalemate trick let me
point that out right away because black
is just one move away from getting a
queen we really cannot stop that with
our king or Knight and if let's say we
start with a push King here he'll be
able to hunt this pawn down so black is
in no danger of let's say white
successfully promoting to a queen in
other words I think I see the idea I
think the idea is hmm to force black to
capture this pawn and also this knight
and then at the end there's this move
King to h3 attacking the pawn and if it
promotes to a rook are a queen it'll be
stalemate which may seem a little bit
awkward but I think the idea is to
actually have this knight sacrifice
itself on the g5 square and after pawn
takes this pawn will be controlling h4
forcing King H well and then when king
h3 is played attacking the pawn black
has to push it and promote to something
a rook our queen it'll be stalemate
because controls all the g5 squares and
h4 will be controlled so how could we
manage that just kind of gathering
information here I believe I know how it
does work the first move is to push most
likely just to generate a threat of
promotion so on h7 King here is
necessary and then this is where it
becomes very important this next move I
think move to is Knight f7 this the
second move I believe is critical
h7 King g7 promoting right away I think
is incorrect because of King takes and
then Knight f7 check King to g7 and
black is just going to promote I think
the idea is to make sure that we can
land on the g5 square with check if the
check is side step with the King moving
then the knight can return to f3 or h3
and B in time to defend against G pond
so therefore I believe the solution will
be h7 King g7 and not the immediate
promotion but rather Knight f7
threatening to promote forcing King
takes h7 and then we play Knight g5
check if the King moves its Knight f3 or
h3 and if the knight is taken pawn takes
Knight with check then we play King h3
and we're an interesting position where
no matter what black promotes 2 if it's
a rook or queen it'll be stalemate and
if it's a knight or Bishop white can
play King g4 it gets a little bit tricky
actually you play King g4 the King can
play - let's say g6 to defend black's
pawn but then there's one key move h4
notice if black is promoting to a minor
piece on g1 and with the king on g4
there is no way to check the King if
there's a knight or Bishop on g1 the
King on g4 there's no way to give check
so even if black comes up to defend the
pawn on g5 there's h4 which would force
the exchanging off of that last pun and
then it'll be insufficient material so I
believe that this is it
h7 first and is correct and now the key
move Knight f7 not promotion right away
that is right Knight g5 check it's
correct and now King h3 don't want to
allow promotion with check and that's as
far as they went but again if
- just go into the analysis board real
quick let me see if I could size this up
here we go yeah so where were we out
here no not that move first push here
Knight f7 I don't know if it's going to
allow me to change into the different I
don't know if I have it set where I
could change into the different pieces
for promotion yeah do so a queen
this is stalemate a rook same story if
it's a bishop we would have King here
the King could play here to defend but
now comes h4 and you cannot avoid the
exchanging off of that the pawn and
it'll be a draw there and then the same
story with the knight king g4 probably
should have taken it out a little bit
more those last two in case of the minor
piece promotion and same story
it'll be insufficient material so I kind
of got the idea in this one pretty quick
I don't know if it's from seeing a
similar type of puzzle previously these
ideas but kind of just going to the
initial position once you see that
there's really no way to stop I bring it
up here once you see that there's no way
to really stop this pawn you have to
look for these little ideas of
constructing a position where your king
could end up in stalemate and it
involved the g5 square and forcing this
pawn here and the main idea was that
second move the key move is Knight f7
this is where it could have a lot of
players go wrong promoting right away
and then trying to get to f7 the idea is
to get to g5 with check and like we saw
King h3 alright well interesting group
of three pretty basic one to start and I
think a pretty cool one to end for this
one so as usual feel free to leave any
feedback in the comment section below
and share how you did with these three
puzzles so that's all for now I hope
you're having a good day take care bye
you